[Music]
the track team was really just a big
family brothers and sisters and the
coaches are your parents keeping you in
line and we would travel together and
close to 40 hours a week together the
track team was very large I think we had
about 40 guy and the same amount of
women we travel to meet with 60 or 70
athletes we bring to a national meet we
brought probably 15 guys and 15 girls
yeah my relationship with Coach lundberg
was really strong he recruited me to
Hillsdale but he's a distance coach
cross country coach but we have a field
events coach who was going to be my
coach it's coached F and he's really the
one who was able to mold me into the
athlete that I became we spend a lot of
time together but there's a lot of trust
that has to happen I have to trust what
they're doing thank goodness coach test
had a lot of experience and he would
give me all the advice that I needed to
change my work outs or keep them the
same or change like staff so it was it
was a great working relationship because
these guys are so easy to get to know
easy to work with and they just love
everyone they work with as long as
you're willing to put in the work and
the time the success that I had as a
collegiate athlete was coupled with
failures as well the failures that I had
were mostly during the season trying
different things but it was an
experiment that coach test and I in
coach lundberg were working to figure
out what was going to be the best to
prepare me for the big dance which is
the National in my freshman year I was
just in the country in the high jump I
have eight times as an all-american I
feel like I represent the teams of the
early 90s we had a great string from 91
92 93 94 we lost the first year of the
GLIAC championship but we never lost
after that I represent coach test coach
coach Martha and I'm just the guy who
gets to get inducted for the whole thing
for them but I just feel like I'm their
representative